Speaker 1: Republican. Senate
Minority Leader Mitch McConnell
is scared. He's scared to disavow Donald Trump
and to say it's time for the Republican Party
to go in a different direction. We know it's
what he thinks. Mitch McConnell made it very
clear in that speech he gave on the floor of
the Senate just days after the January six,
2021, Trump riots. We know that Mitch McConnell
is not pleased with Trump. He is not pleased with
Trump politically. He's not pleased with
Trump ideologically. I can't imagine that
he sees Trump positively after Trump has made
numerous racist comments and dog whistles about
Mitch McConnell's own wife, Elaine Chao, based
on her Asian heritage. There's no way in hell
for all of the bad things we can say about Mitch
McConnell. There's no way in hell Mitch McConnell
is a Trump guy. But Mitch McConnell also in many
cases, puts politics above his individual beliefs
and above principle. And so Mitch McConnell isn't
willing to say, I don't want Trump to be the next
nominee and I don't want Trump to be the next
president. Mitch McConnell is saying I will vote
for whoever ultimately is the nominee. And in
fact, yesterday he was asked by CNN's Manu Raju
on the heels of Nikki Haley announcing that she,
too, is running for the Republican presidential
nomination, he was asked, will you support
Nikki Haley? And he sort of said, well, it's
going to be very competitive. And then he said he
will support whoever is ultimately the nominee.
Speaker 3: In light of Nikki Haley's.
Speaker 1: Decision to jump in the
race today, do you think that it's time for the
party to find a fresh face and move away.
Speaker 4: From Donald Trump? Well, what I
think we're going to have is a vigorous primary,
vigorous a number of candidates making their case
and the American people, those who are ready.
Should Republicans who are going to participate in
these primaries are going to decide who they want
to nominate? And I think it's going to be very,
very competitive in these primaries, and we'll
hope for the best. And obviously, I'm going to
support whoever the nominee ultimately is.
Speaker 1: Obviously, obviously, there is
no scenario in which Mitch McConnell would not
support whoever is the eventual nominee. Now,
there are people who will write to me and say,
David, that it's really not a big deal, that Mitch
McConnell is saying that he's a Republican. He's
in Republican leadership. Of course, he's going
to support whoever the candidate ultimately is.
We know that. No, I get that. The problem is that
it's a brazen partizanship where for the good of
the country, I would like to see Mitch McConnell
at least be open to the idea that if the nominee
were truly horrible, he would think for himself.
And even though I know he would never say it,
it would be nice to hear from Mitch McConnell.
Something along the lines of, listen, I am a
Republican and I have faith that Republicans will
select the best candidate to represent us. But
I am not a blind follower and I am not a moral.
And while I disagree with Joe Biden, he is a good
man and an honest man who wants what he believes
is best for the country. And if indeed the
Republican Party selected someone that I believe
would be destructive to this country, I would
cross party lines. He never going to do it. It's,
of course, never going to do it. He will always
end up justifying the vote for the Republican. But
I would like to see them at least pretend not to
be overtly partizan hacks. They would be lying in
a sense. So am I saying I would like to see them
like. Well, though I would love for that to be the
truth. It is not. And so Mitch McConnell is being
honest. Yeah. Trump said racist things about my
wife. Yeah. Trump incited insurrection. Yeah. I've
said Trump is a problem in so many different ways,
but I'm going to vote for whoever is the nominee,
even if that is Donald Trump. And this is similar
to the Bill Barr line. When we saw these
recent interviews by Bill William Barr,
Trump's former attorney general, criticize Trump
significantly and then say, Well, I'm not going
to vote for a Democrat, obviously not going to
vote for a Democrat. They are telling the truth
in that sense. And at least for once, they aren't
lying. But Mitch McConnell making it very clear,
whoever they put up there, he would vote for
over a Democrat will have these clips available
for you on our YouTube channel, YouTube.com
slash The David Pakman Show. We also have
the YouTube channel in Spanish now available.
Closing in on our first thousand subscribers
on the Spanish YouTube channel, which you
can find at U to actually, you know what?
I'm going to set up a redirect. David Pakman dot
com slash Spanish. Okay. Just to make it easier.
David Pakman dot com slash Spanish will take
you to the Spanish language YouTube channel.